and while we do that
also i'd love to to hear from you all
what kind of roles you're looking for
which nanodegree program did you
complete and which roles are you looking
for
that'll help give me some context since
we have a smaller group today
so if you're just joining let me know
where you're calling in from
and for those of you who are already in
here let me know which nanodegree
program you took
or are currently taking and then what
types of jobs you're looking for
so omar did the machine learning
nanodegree very cool
what else who else do we have in the
room
also looking for machine learning
engineer roles very cool
pursuing ai for healthcare great space
to be in
what else
data engineering also another great
space you all are kind of doing some
similar things here
machine learning deep learning computer
vision all of you guys should be
you know getting to know each other
you're all kind of in the same space
it's a great great place to be and a
great place to network
jonathan i see data analyst another
great one as well
kevin cloud computing awesome you're
like the only one who's not within the
data science machine learning as of
right now but that is okay
we love to see people from different
backgrounds all very
in-demand spaces for you all to be
uh let's see i haven't decided yet still
working on my nanodegree that's not a
problem either
um you know maybe through this i'll help
you figure out which which path to
pursue
uh product management and ross says
intermediate python
which is a work in progress starting
from web development see how it goes
very cool i mean that you got to start
somewhere and
you're more advanced than i am so there
is
some kudos for you there um i
started the intro to programming
nanodegree and didn't make it all the
way through so i'll leave the technical
expertise to you all
and you all can leave the personal
branding and career support to me
great um so let's go ahead and jump in
and get started
um if you do have questions along the
way please feel free to
kind of drop them in the chat or you can
hop on your microphone we do have a
smaller group today about 12 people
so smaller than we normally have which
means you all can ask a little bit more
individualized questions
this session is not meant to be a
lecture
so i don't want to talk at you guys for
the next hour i am going to be sharing
some best practices and some tips
but i really want you all to engage i
want to get your questions answered i
want you to leave this feeling confident
entering a job search for 2021 and even
if you're not
aggressively searching right now this is
a great place to be to learn
how to put yourself in a position to
where you can be successful
in a job search so a little bit about me
um so my career really started in
education so i went to school to be a
business teacher
and then i transitioned into colleges
and universities working with college
students
um and now kind of shifted over to
adults and ed tech
and kind of working with people who are
going through similar programs as you
all
so when you talk to different career
coaches some of them will have areas
that they focus on and i think my
specialization is within personal
branding
and showcasing your impact so really
making a name for yourself and becoming
recognized as a subject matter expert in
your field of choice
that's one of the areas that i focus on
because i've always seen
job searching as more of a marketing
activity than anything
because i want you all and all of my
students and clients to put themselves
in a position
where they're the ones in demand i don't
want you guys always having to be the
ones to apply
and reach out i want you to be in a
position where you are attracting
recruiters
and if you're freelancing or
entrepreneurs as well i want you to be
passively attracting those people
um and that business potentially if
that's what you're looking for that's
kind of my area of expertise
so you'll see that coming in and out
throughout today's presentation as well
as any other
webinars that i've facilitated and as i
mentioned this is one of my favorite
parts of this role is being able to
engage with a global audience
as we saw earlier in the chat we have
people from all over the world
um and being able to kind of bring you
all together so as i mentioned
i do not want to be talking at you for
the entire time
so in thinking about how to best
participate
really participation and value go hand
in hand you'll get the most out of this
session
if you're active and if you're involved
if you're just listening to it in the
background that's okay as well but
you're not going to get as much out of
it as those who are actively engaged
so if you can please turn on your camera
your microphone
this is a great opportunity for you to
build and network
um if you do want to speak just make
sure that you unmute your microphone but
keep it muted while others are speaking
just for some housekeeping rules here
one other thing that i want to mention
is do not be self-conscious about your
english i talk to you to ask these
students all the time
who are afraid that people are going to
judge them this is a safe space
nobody here is evaluating you for a job
nobody here is judging you
or your background and one of the things
that i always like to tell people is
that
if you speak english as well as another
language that's an advantage that's not
a disadvantage and i want people to see
that
and and be able to speak with confidence
even if they're not the best
english speakers being bilingual is
something that can really set you apart
in a job search
especially now that we're operating in
more of a global economy
and you're able to really work from
anywhere so
as you might have have known i speak a
little bit quickly i get really
passionate about this work and so if i'm
going too fast
please let me know i will do my best to
slow down and enunciate
so that you can understand everything
that i am saying
um and then lastly for this session
specifically i wanted to make it clear
again this is not designed for me to
talk at you for an entire hour this is
more so
designed to be discussion based and q a
style so
each slide is going to kind of cover a
major topic i'll speak on it for a
little bit
and then i want you to ask questions
related to that i'd love if you could
turn your microphones on to ask those
questions
and then also if you have previous
successes with this i'd love for you to
share as well
um once again we do have a smaller group
so
if i'm talking about something and you
think oh i have a good example of that
or i've done that in the past and it's
worked i'd love
to hear you share that with the group um
or if you have answers to some people's
questions that i might not have
um as i mentioned before it's important
to recognize that i
am not a nanodegree content expert i am
also not a technical expert
so your questions that are more
technical
or more so related to your expertise i'm
not necessarily going to be able to help
with that unless it is areas that i'm
familiar with
and so there may be others in the room
who can potentially help you
with uh some of those questions that
might be a little bit more technical
that i'm just not the best to answer
so let's go ahead and
jump in i want to hear from you all
again um you can jump in the chat or you
can turn on your microphone and we'll
try to go one at a time
but i want to know from you all what do
you believe is your biggest barrier to
landing a job
i'm really interested in hearing this i
ask this question to every single
student that i coach
and so i want to know off the top of
your head
what do you feel like is the biggest
thing that's that's holding you back
right now from landing a new role
even if you haven't jumped in and
started job searching yet
what do you think might be your biggest
hurdle to jump
can i go
um all right so uh first of all uh hello
everyone this is aladdin
so i see not being certain what i want
to do that's definitely one of
the topics we'll talk about today uh
moto
says skills i i'd love for you to be a
little bit more specific and what you
mean by that
what else hello can you hear me
hello
hello can you hear me ross says for me
it's technical expertise that's why i'm
a nanodegree student well you are
in the right place so hopefully um
you're in a position where you're
kind of being a little bit more
intentional in your career
path so you may not be aggressive in
your job search but
this i think will help you to figure out
what you should be focused on what you
can be learning and how to
kind of hit the ground running when you
are ready to be really aggressive with
that job search so i'm glad you're here
kevin says not having actual work
experience with the technology yes that
is a tough one to grasp
let's see uh you can't hear us
no i can't i can't hear you
it looks like some people are muted
can you hear me hello
hello oh there we go man
i had mine muted for a second i'm so
sorry
go ahead no problem so can you hear me
now
yes i can i apologize for that no
problem no
no problem thank you so much for giving
me this opportunity so yeah i guess it's
the main problem is experience
especially if
you are kind of fresh graduated
so that's a big problem especially like
if you if at least for my in my case if
i want to join the
product management field and yeah that's
really really big challenge though
yeah absolutely it's one of the biggest
challenges that i think
most udacity students have especially
those who are transitioning into
something they haven't done before
or trying to transition into something
new and so that's something that that
we're going to talk about today as well
yeah thank you for sharing i see also in
the chat not being able to sell yourself
during the interview
i don't know that we'll touch too too
much on the interview just um on today's
session but there are plenty of
resources that we have
out there for that i mean if we have
time towards the end since we do have a
smaller group please kind of
put that in your back pocket and bring
it back up towards the end
yes have the skills and but not able to
explain it i gotcha
and omar says um i don't know the real
problem i have made many interviews and
all of them told me that i have very
good skills but didn't receive any
offers okay
so um that's another thing that that you
know i hope to jump into today so thank
you all for
for sharing that and now my speakers are
on so i can definitely hear you
um if you do have additional questions
or want to continue to share
so let's jump into my first
tip of the day so my first
big tip is know what employers want to
see
and the reason why this is so important
it goes back to that point i mentioned
earlier about how my focus as it relates
to job searching
is more of a marketing approach i'm not
the type of person who wants to be
aggressive and cold calling and doing
all the like sales type of approaches
i want people to come to me and so think
about
how businesses run i want you to start
putting yourself in the position as if
you are a business or if you are selling
yourself
as a product or service to others people
don't just want what you have
you have to be able to know what they
want
and then appeal to what they want so
this is really kind of step one before
we kind of really move forward in
talking about how to put together your
resume how to build your linkedin
profile
who to network with what to say during
the interviews if you don't
know what they want to see then you're
really setting yourself up for failure
because think about it like this a
kind of an easy one to talk about might
be let's talk about mcdonald's i'm sure
everybody has heard of mcdonald's knows
the
the fast food restaurant mcdonald's they
don't
have commercials bragging about how
awesome their business is
they don't talk about how much money
they made in their commercials they
don't talk about
you know what what their stock price is
right now
they appeal to your needs they show you
juicy dripping burgers and crispy
crunchy french fries because that's
appealing to your needs as a human
that's appealing to your emotions
of hunger and so when it comes to these
specific employers
you want to kind of start with an idea
in mind this is
where it can be a little bit challenging
when you don't know where you're going
because then you don't know which
employers that you're targeting you
don't know what they want because you're
just kind of
casting a wide net you're doing the
spray and pray
approach to applying for any jobs that
you see fit
and it oftentimes doesn't produce
successful results even if it does lead
to an interview
oftentimes those roles that end up
getting filled are more so
from people that they know um or people
who have done a little bit more
in-depth research or have direct
experience into
that industry so it's really important
that you learn these things and so
a couple of strategies that you can
implement to understand what employers
want to see
are informational interviews which i
know you're probably
going to want to want to know how do i
reach out to people who work at the
companies i want to work with
that's definitely an important thing to
consider but you also can explore
different things like looking on
linkedin going to the company that you
want to work for and looking at the
people who are in those roles
so if you want to be a machine learning
engineer
at google let's say for example
go on linkedin and look at all the
machine learning engineers see what
previous experience
they have do you match up to that can
you
fill that gap in a reasonable amount of
time
those are things that you can do to kind
of understand how you might be qualified
if you're seeing what their machine
learning engineers are doing
and you don't have anything close to
that you're probably not google material
right now and that is
okay that is all right not everybody's
going to be a google employee it just
does not work that way so you may want
to target smaller companies
and find things that are a little bit
more in alignment with what you're able
to be competitive for
but on on the topic of informational
interviews
um you can try connecting with some of
these people on linkedin
again when you target those major huge
tech companies
their inboxes are flooded from people
just like you
you're not special you're not standing
out in that messaging and so
keep those things in mind when you're
doing that outreach
and one thing that people oftentimes say
is that you know when i ask them about
their networking strategy
they say oh yeah i'm reaching out to
recruiters on linkedin
that's not networking that's begging a
stranger for a job
and that doesn't often work out too well
either
sometimes you might have success for
that with that um
but more often than not you're better
off connecting with those people who are
in the roles that you want
because they're gonna have a better
indication of what you need to bring
in order to do well in those types of
roles and so
trying to connect with them on a more
personal level not just sending them
your resume and asking for
30 minutes to talk to them really trying
to level with someone and genuinely
network
share resources add value to them
have conversations about things that you
have in common
those are things that you can do to
really spark that conversation and have
that lead to an informational interview
you can also look at websites um
to see you know maybe there are reddit
threads or things that people are
talking about
what they've done in their interview
process or in their hiring process to
get
noticed um but it's really important
that you understand this
and so um any thoughts or questions
related to this topic before
we jump to the next tip a lot of it's
going to overlap so you might hear a
couple things two or three times some
new things here and there but are there
any
specific questions or or thoughts
related to this specific tip
uh hi um i have
like one about your uh your
mentioned uh strategy
that's um i don't ask about
the challenge you are right that
um how to save yourself or how to to
come up with an idea that
uh ready to be uh published
to the the international community like
um uh i'm good at at this point
uh how can i how can like determine this
point
uh at the first place and then
[Music]
uh how how how can i say like i am good
at this
at this scale and um
how can like i know how it is uh where
am i
in the competition in the competition uh
with other practitioners
uh this is really a big concern for me
right now
yeah so as it as it relates specifically
to
some of those like getting known um or
becoming recognized for your work
linkedin is a great platform to do that
um
linkedin is a great place for you to
share the work that you're doing
you can add links on your profile to
your github
you can create content and create posts
for other people to see
so um you know one of the things that i
encourage you to ask these students to
think about is
you know whenever you finish a project
for your nanodegree share that on
linkedin
um write a brief summary of what you did
and then educate people a little bit
one of the things that i see a lot on
linkedin is that people just kind of
brag
and they are sharing this is what i did
look at me look at me look at me
and and that can work but what i think
is also a little bit more engaging
that can get more people to like and
comment on your
content and your posts is to actually
teach them something
so i often tell people to brag and teach
so if you're saying look at me
i just completed this new project on uh
with udacity tag udacity on um
how to do this whatever it is and then
share that
share something that's visual don't just
put like a text
um post maybe share a screenshot
or share something that might be a
little bit more visually appealing to
someone as they're scrolling through
uh that can be really helpful for to to
get people's attention
but then also making sure that you're on
that platform connecting with other
people who are in the same space as you
so you know if you wanted to
connect with other people in in your
nanodegree program
um and then post content and and try to
engage with other people who are doing
the same thing as well
that's how you build awareness for the
work that you're doing
that's how you start to draw more
traffic to your profile
which is great for recruiters who are
out and actively looking for people
so i would say linkedin is a great place
to start i would also say
be very intentional about the projects
that you're building in your nanodegree
program don't just rush to get that
certificate
take your time focus on those projects
because those are going to be things
that you use to build your portfolio
and then share that you know let people
into your work let people see that's
that's how these recruiters know people
that they want to reach out to
um to to potentially interview so i
would say linkedin is a great place to
start
um once we get towards the the end of
the session i'll be sure to drop a link
on a webinar
that i facilitated with udacity on that
topic
but yeah that's a that's a really good
question i think you want to
first have a solid confidence in your
skill set
that's usually what i see is lacking
before people are ready to kind of start
publishing their work and being
confident about it write articles do
things like that
so that goes right in alignment with
this next tip is to really
find your focus or narrow your focus so
for those of you who don't know what you
want to do
i would say it's really important that
you kind of try to figure that out
and one of the things that i don't want
you to do is try to figure out what
you're going to do for the rest of your
career
i don't want you to try to figure out
what you're going to do for the rest of
your entire life
i want you to focus on kind of an ideal
next step
because that releases a lot of that
stress a lot of that pressure
a lot of that i need to figure
everything out you're never going to
i'll i'll let you know now there are
plenty of people here at
various different stages in their career
who at any given moment
might say you know i don't know that
this is exactly what i want to do and
that's okay
it's okay that you never find that it's
okay that you continue to search and
continue to explore and do things that
are interesting to you
but i would say if you want to have kind
of a really successful job search
narrowing that focus can be really
helpful some people think if i
open my options up as wide as possible
i'm going to be considered for more
opportunities
it doesn't necessarily work that way
sometimes you have more success
when you narrow it down so so small that
those people are a lot more excited
about you so
again going back to the comparison of
you
as a business businesses don't just
target
any person who wants to buy their
services a lot of businesses have really
specified target markets they know
exactly who they're targeting
so when they do their ads they can say i
want i
want a woman who is between the ages of
25 and 34
who has a college education like they
are going that specific
and that's what helps them to get those
customers excited
so when you think about it in relation
to your job search
it can be really beneficial if all of
your udacity projects are related to the
same topics
or if all of your passion projects or
side work
are within the same industry or focus on
the same
kind of types of companies if you are
out here and trying to freelance and
you're
you know doing something for this and
you're doing something related to this
and you're doing something related to
this
it can help to kind of showcase you as a
generalist
but if you say i have projects related
to
this industry i have eight projects
related to
health care that's going to help you
land health care jobs
now if you have health care and media
and sports and you know random things
all over the place it's not going to
make you as appealing to those types of
employers
it also makes it difficult for you to
network if you are connecting with
machine learning engineers across
the world in various different
industries
that can be beneficial but there's also
a huge benefit to saying
i'm going to focus my my attention
on machine learning engineers that work
in the healthcare space or i'm going to
focus
mine on people who work in the education
space
because those are going to allow you to
get to know people easier
those people can facilitate additional
introductions
and you'll start to recognize like who
the the major players are in that
industry
so that you can kind of try to get to
know them and then become one of those
people
you don't have to become a world's
leading expert within your industry
but having that focus can be really
beneficial
um especially in the current job market
where we've seen the pandemic really
take a toll on the amount of positions
available
so it's good for you to stand out as a
leading expert
in healthcare ai or
as a leading expert in cloud computing
within tech companies or or something
like that
so having that focus can be really
beneficial
any any thoughts or questions related to
that yes
i do have a question okay
you can hear me so basically it seems
what you talked about is more or less
the persona
uh or recruitment persona from that from
the hr
my question is how can i figure that
persona
out so since it's more or less kind of
like internal document for the business
or for the company
and i am a person who's external want to
apply so how can i figure out that
persona so in order to say okay i am fit
for that company or not or more or less
i can give it a shot you got what i'm
saying
yeah i think i i wouldn't say to to to
try to find that persona necessarily
within a specific
company i think that that can be helpful
um but i'm talking about kind of just
industry-wide finding the people who are
kind of well-known within that industry
but if you are thinking about like how
to connect with people within specific
companies
i am a big believer that you should be
connecting with people at the same level
as you
so if you are trying to enter a company
you're probably not going to want to
reach out to the cto
at a major tech firm you're probably
going to reach out to the person who is
entry level and whatever you're trying
to get into
one those people are going to be less
busy responding to requests from other
people
two you're probably going to have more
in common because they're going to be
most closely related to that experience
that you're going through
to be able to say you know i was going
through the same thing these are the
things that i did
but then also you want to connect with
people that you connect to
you don't want to force relationships
with people just to get a job
those that doesn't work well um just in
my experience and the people that i've
talked to the people who are landing
great jobs at great companies are not
doing this
one-sided parasitic type of networking
they're engaging with people who have
similar interests so they're
almost friends like in a sense you know
you have things in common outside of
just the role outside of just the work
and you're building genuine
relationships with those people and
you're continuing those relationships as
you grow your career
and so that would be my recommendation
is when you're looking for that specific
persona
focus more so on things that you have in
common versus
where they fall in in the organization
but also try to target those people who
are within your level
and within those roles versus reaching
out to the hr manager
reaching out to the recruiter or some
random person in sales
um focus on the people who are in kind
of the same space that would be my
recommendation
um i have a question here
and i'd like you to ask to answer it
like please
um my question is what are
the factors that you should be retraced
uh in your uh in your generator
narrowing your focus and um
like um
make it as coherent as possible
uh should it be like uh
the money barrier uh for this job
opportunity should it be like
uh number of job opportunities available
for
this position um
what are the two factors that you should
be retraced uh i
i i i want to know what so
that that's very personal i think you
know when it comes down to that that's
going
to ultimately depend on your values the
things that you're looking for
if you know one of the things that i've
been trying to talk to people about
is you know we're not in an ideal job
market if you
aren't if you're not coming with a
highly competitive background
and a kind of plethora of different
experiences that are related to your
role
it's not a good idea for people to say
you know i'm gonna target the top
companies that are paying the highest
like
it's just unrealistic and i'm usually
the career coach who's saying
go for your dream job shoot for the
stars and now we're dealing with a
pandemic that has devastated the job
market
the other thing to consider is that for
a lot of you
you're working in building a skill set
and things that are
i don't want to say they're ahead of
their time but they
haven't become universal just yet so
you're developing a skill set that is
going to be extremely high in demand
as time goes on and so i don't want you
to think about this current job market
where my success thus far in a job
search
is reflective of what it's going to be
like forever you're developing a skill
set that you know you chose for a reason
and so that demand for that skill set is
only going to continue to grow
as businesses realize how important it
is to have cloud computing solutions and
realize how they can implement you know
lower level machine learning into the
work that they're doing to automate
processes and make things easy so
i would say if you're in the initial
stages don't shoot
for the top you know shoot for something
that
is going to get you closer to the top if
you say my dream job is to is to work at
google
don't make that a three month goal make
that a three year goal
and then let's create smaller steps
that get you there much easily that
doesn't mean you don't still try for
those
but it's it's almost you know setting
yourself up for unrealistic expectations
and you
you let that pressure and like that that
stress eat at you and make you feel like
you're not good enough because you can't
get a job there
just don't put that pressure of trying
to do it so quickly that that would be
my recommendation
um we're gonna move on just for the sake
of time
um i see jonathan you put something
about how to build a portfolio
so that's a little bit more in depth we
could probably do an entire session on
that
one thing that i will say is to um
i would say you know it's great to have
things that are a little bit more
visually appealing and not just
code so maybe you know sometimes it
helps to create like a case study
maybe make like a powerpoint
presentation or something visual to go
along with things that might be a little
bit more technical
i am on the position that every single
person should have a portfolio
i don't care what you do it's something
that can really help you stand apart
from your competition
i have a portfolio for all kinds of
different things i have portfolios
related to digital marketing
i have portfolios related to teaching i
have portfolios related to
all kinds of different things because
when i'm going for roles i want to be
able to showcase those different things
uh yeah um i i will i will look into it
uh having that portfolio session just
one more thing please if like if you are
going too well
like to have like to create a session
for about the portfolio it would be nice
if you can like
um like explain from the very beginning
like what is portfolio actually and so
on because to be honest
i am hearing this word a lot in my
career
or like sorry like in in my like in
general my experience but i really don't
know exactly what portfolio is
or what it should be and right now you
make it you are
you you just made it right now more
confusing for me because he said you
believe that
purple you should you are one of those
people should like that
in every single career you should have a
portal for you which
i i believe like portfolio should be
like in a specific field but you said no
in every single feed so that's why if
you
are going to create that session it
would be nice if you like start from the
very
basic about like what's portugal yeah so
abs absolutely let me let me clarify
what i meant so i think every individual
should have a portfolio
that showcases their best work that
showcases their best work related to
what they want to do
the reason why i have so many different
things is because my career has been a
little bit all over the place i like to
explore different areas and try
different things
but if you because when you think about
a lot of the work that you do
as a technical work people want to dive
in they want to see that code they want
to see what you've created
the same thing is if you were to go and
buy something
from a company or hire a web developer
to build a website for you
you're gonna want to see what they've
done previously and so this isn't
necessarily something that
is required but it is something that can
help set you apart from other people
but yeah definitely something that i
have to um explore a little bit further
that would take a lot more work to put
together
just because it would look so different
from different areas but yeah
think about how you might be able to do
that that is also part of your job
search a job search does not just
include
applying for jobs online a job search
also includes
building your portfolio creating
projects that are related to what you
want to do
don't wait for people to give you those
jobs do them yourself as a way to to
prepare for those opportunities
so we talked about this a little bit but
the next tip is to always always always
consider the competition
so most people when they're going
through a job search process
they'll think okay how can i showcase to
this employer that i'm qualified to do
this job
they oftentimes don't think about how am
i going to stand
apart from the other people that are
applying so on
average jobs get about 200 applicants
you're one of them
at the end of that process one person
wins
one person wins unless they're hiring
for multiple roles 199 people
lose they're losers that is the reality
of this process you know for each
individual position you're not
you know losers in the grand scheme of
things but
it's really important to think how you
can come at this process
with a unique edge again go back to the
kind of the the comparison to being a
business
how do those businesses stand apart from
from other businesses that's what gets
people to choose them
and so uh having a portfolio could be
what sets you apart from the competition
having a connection within the company
could be what sets you apart from the
competition
having um you know a specific focus on
an
industry where your previous experiences
all in one area versus other people
could be what sets you apart
if you're transitioning into a different
industry maybe
try to focus maybe maybe try to stay
within that industry
with doing something different so a
recent example i have is
um i was talking to a student who was
doing the
data analyst nanodegree and previously
he was a math teacher and so he was
trying to
land like a data analyst role at like
these top tech companies
and i was telling him he wasn't going to
be very competitive but
if he were to focus on trying to get a
data analyst role at an education
company
or at an ed tech company or at an
education non-profit
something related to his past that could
be what sets him apart from the other
data analysts with potentially more
experience
because he has ground level experience
working with students
he can provide that perspective that
other candidates probably wouldn't have
so as you go through this process again
this is
also a part of your job search thinking
how do i stand apart from other people
is it going to be through my connections
is it going to be through my portfolio
is it going to be through my
uniquely relevant experience those are
things that you want to
consider especially as it relates to the
types of companies that you're targeting
because if you're going for these big
big name companies with these high
salaries
um the biggest companies in the world
and you're not competitive with some of
those people
then you're doing yourself a disservice
plus the biggest companies in the world
aren't necessarily the best companies to
work for and that's one thing that a lot
of people tend to forget
is that they think oh this company's
doing so well i want to work there
you could find probably a better job a
better experience
at either a smaller company or a medium
sized company
obviously not always the case but don't
set those black and white
ideas in your head because there's a lot
of gray area when it comes to
companies in the employee experience but
always consider the competition is very
very important
this is a big one this one usually
strikes a chord with most of my clients
and students because this
is usually plan a and the only plan
when i talk to people about their job
search strategy a lot of people are only
applying for jobs online that is
all they're doing they're casting a wide
net looking for things that match the
job title and just applying
sending the same resume over and over
and over and over and they expect people
to take them seriously
i i want to challenge people who think
that way if you're taking
10 minutes to apply for a job that
doesn't really make you a standout
candidate for those roles
so what i would say to do is
prioritize networking networking is
going to give you the most return on
your
investment over time as well as
in a short term job search because
referrals are by far the top way to get
hired and really always have been
i think the the statistics show that
between 40 to 60 percent of all people
hired in general come as a result of a
referral
so somebody who is recommending them
from the inside or
somebody who is close saying hey you
should check this person out
and so that's why networking should be
your plan a
your top priority your main focus and
it's also something that you should
never stop doing
that's not to say that you need to be at
a networking event twice a week
but it is to say that even if you're in
a job that you absolutely love
you should still be networking you
should still be building your network
with people in your industry so that if
things do happen
or if you are ready to make a transition
you are able to pivot much more easily
because if you apply online going back
to the competition slide
1 out of 199 you really think your
resume
is going to be the one that stands out
from everybody
else's that's probably not the case the
other thing to consider is that a lot of
companies use what are called applicant
tracking systems
has anybody heard of applicant tracking
systems or an ats
they are tracking certain keywords uh
that yeah they are looking for like uh
uh are you looking
for a scale uh uh uh a person who
are scared at uh uh python or
django or something yes yep
yeah omar you hit it right on the head
so um
to provide a little bit more of context
yes it's it's kind of like a bot
it's basically a software program
that companies use to scan job
descriptions
and then scan resumes and compare them
to see how well you might fit
so it's a terrible system
most people don't know that they exist
most companies have not found a better
way around it but think about it like
this and then i'll get into the ins and
outs of the system
when technology evolved to where
companies can start putting their job
applications online
that means any person in the world
at any time with any background
can apply for that job what makes that
difficult on the receiving end or on the
hiring end
is now you're having hundreds sometimes
thousands of applications
you don't have the manpower to
physically review
each individual resume it's just not
possible
so they've implemented these software
systems that scan job descriptions when
they're uploaded
and from those job descriptions it will
say
what words keep popping up or what words
seem
important from this job description so
if you're applying for
a oh let me see if you're applying let's
say you're applying for a machine
learning role
and it has a focus on like computer
vision maybe that that's the focus if
that job description has computer vision
on it
five times it's going to be looking to
see if your resume
has computer vision as a keyword on
there about as many times
so if you don't have computer vision on
there or you only have it on there once
you're going to receive a lower score
than you would if you had it on there as
many times as a job description
now if computer vision is on there five
times and you put
computer vision 10 times on your resume
you don't get any extra bonus points but
they're kind of measuring
about how well your resume matches that
job description
so it's really really important that you
review
each individual job description
carefully a lot of people are just
sending the same resume as fast as they
can to as many different places
sometimes that leads to interviews but
if you want to land a good job and want
to have more successful job searches
you need to review each individual job
description carefully
you need to focus on fewer roles more
targeted approach
and tailor each individual resume or cv
that you send out
to match that job description so it
sounds like a lot of work
that's because it is that's because
companies want people who are willing to
put in the work
even at the beginning stages of a hiring
process
you're not going to have a ton of
success like i mentioned just sending
the same exact resume to every single
position because
one machine learning engineer position
might not have computer vision on it at
all
whereas one might have it five or six
times and so
when you send that resume in that's
going to determine how successful you
are
a lot of companies will kind of
designate
a threshold to say that this resume
needs to match the job description at 40
um and anything that falls below 40 due
to the
algorithm of the applicant tracking
system
doesn't even get seen by a person it's
like balling up your resume and throwing
it in the trash can
if the company's using one of those
systems uh i'd like to share an idea
about this particular point like
uh a good a good way to manage your
resumes or your cvs is to have
a version control version control of
your cv
that you can manage it to
to to to add multiple skills uh uh
for your uh target jobs that
uh this will really reduce the headache
of
editing your cv multiple times and
saving it and
get like confused about which cv you
have saved uh
like i i i just found this
idea is a good idea to
to to attack exists overwhelming
yeah that's a that's a good idea and so
i think it's important that
you do have different versions of your
resume if you are going to target
different types of roles but then also
uh making it easy to make those changes
i think is important so some people will
have a section
where they talk about their skills they
may call it something different like
expertly trained in or core competencies
or
major strengths whatever and then they
list the keywords directly from the job
description
and sometimes that makes it easier for
them to swap things in and out
but going back to the the slide
applying online should not be your plan
a and so
even if you create the most perfectly
tailored resume to the job description
that does not guarantee
interviews and when you think about it
one out of 200 people is
half a percent of a chance of getting a
job i don't like those odds
if it's me i'm prioritizing networking
i'm
focused on the types of companies that i
want to work for and i'm
aggressive about trying to connect with
the people that work with those
companies
because those referrals lead to more job
openings
lead to more job offers it makes sense
for me to put most of my time
in the bucket where people get most job
offers not
to spend my time doing what everybody
else is doing that goes again back to
the competition if you do what everyone
else does
you're never going to stand out
especially if your resume isn't
perfect so think about other ways that
you can kind of
approach your job search strategy and
make sure that networking is at the
forefront
so leading to our next point it's time
to get used to it
and now that we're not able to meet in
person as much get used to virtual
networking
so linkedin is a great place to do this
uh
meetup is a great place to do this and
also just doing a google search
of virtual communities in computer
vision virtual communities in cloud
computing
virtual communities and digital
marketing these are places that you want
to
be in getting to know people learning
where they work
finding time to get to speak with them
and then also as i mentioned before
don't be that person who approaches this
from one-sided don't be that parasitic
person
who's like give me give me give me also
be that person who is saying
here's a resource that i found i think
you would really benefit from it
i just took this udacity nanodegree
course it was amazing
you should check it out here are my
notes you know
i don't know um but some of the best
networking that i've done have even been
off the topic of professional
some of my best kind of business friends
i've met at events that are unrelated to
you know networking or i.t or
career stuff it's people i met at a
music event or someone i met
at a restaurant that we both went to
multiple times
so you don't have to be that person who
says oh i have all this to offer
it could just be showcasing to the other
person that you are
genuinely genuinely interested in in
getting to know them
genuinely interested in building a
relationship with them and gender
genuinely interested in having a
mutually beneficial relationship
one that goes both ways one that is not
just give me a referral give me a
referral it's
you know asking about them trying to get
to know them trying to build with them
work on a project together collaborate
on an article
put together an event for your peers
these are things that you can do to
really build solid foundations and
relationships with people but you want
to explore what are those virtual
channels that you can still do this
because a lot of those virtual
communities within the space that you're
looking for
are hosting events they have private job
boards they're willing to give referrals
without
ever meeting in person or meeting
virtually
um it's just that you're in that same
group and they they want to help other
people in that group
so this should be plan a right now
landing a job at landing a good job at a
good company in 2021
my biggest recommendation prioritize
virtual networking i would say this is
this is going to lead to the most
success
and it's hard it is difficult to do this
it is
difficult to start doing this it's one
of those things that snowballs
in a good way so it starts small and as
you build your network it gets bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
easier and easier and easier to land
jobs
that's why you see the people who have
risen to the top of their careers
oftentimes guess who their friends are
other people
at the top of other companies they
aren't always
making friends then they were friends
here and they grew up together
and so if you want to build long-term
career success
not just trying to land a quick job
really quickly if you want to land
something over time and build a career
you need to prioritize networking and
networking has the most potential return
of investment of your time
in the long run if you spend 10 hours
applying for jobs online
and don't get any interviews you wasted
10 hours of your time
if you spend 10 hours networking those
relationships can help you get a job now
they could help you get a job maybe in
two years maybe they don't
provide anything right now but they help
you down the road because you've taken
time to build into that relationship and
prioritize networking
i can't stress how important and how
valuable it is
but yeah any major questions related to
this i wanna i wanna keep moving just
for the sake of time but
um yes let's talk about more networking
um i agree any any thoughts or major
questions related to virtual networking
nope all right cool moving on okay
oh yeah go ahead sorry sorry brad hello
everybody and
i would like to ask about uh virtual
how can we use another virtualbit
networking besides
the common linkedin
another way yeah so
linkedin i would say is a great place to
start one because you can be very
intentional and very targeted
so if you say if you put together a list
of companies which i highly recommend
that helps you to narrow your focus put
together a list of 10 to 15
companies and then you can make it a
habit of saying okay i want to
land a cloud computing job at one of
these 15 companies
then what you can do is go on linkedin
and search for cloud computing
professionals within those companies
and then be very targeted with your
outreach linkedin is the best for that
if you want to be specific but i do
think it's helpful to have a balance of
very targeted networking and then also
more organic genuine um networking where
you're exploring other channels
so meetup um as i mentioned before is
great
um i know it's primarily used in the us
but i i'm pretty sure there are other
meetup groups abroad but that one's
great because you could potentially
find people there there are meetup
groups related to everything there are
meetup groups related to fitness
video games but there are also
professional meetup groups um
that you can check out and see if there
are any locally but one of the cool
things about meetup
now as a result of covid is that you're
able to network
outside of your current location so if
you really wanted to work
in barcelona and you lived
in germany that would be very difficult
to network break over but now a lot of
those groups have shifted to virtual
they have events they're having speed
networking they're doing things to where
you look at that silver lining and see
how can i take advantage of this
situation
if you wanted to move there you could
start building a network of people
in another place where you wouldn't have
been able to do before covet because
they would have been having all of their
networking events in person
and so now that everything is moved to
virtual you can explore those different
channels
um and then the only thing that i'm
having a little bit of difficulty with
is
providing recommendations on a global
scale it's really really difficult for
me to keep track of every single
networking channel across the globe in
addition of
you know trying to stay in touch with
different specific technical expertises
so obviously most of my knowledge and
resources are us-based
but i would just say do do a couple of
google searches do some independent
research
look at networking channels within your
specific area
the more specific you can get the better
because if you're
going to uh people in tech meetup group
that can be helpful but you're going to
talk to people in hr people in sales
people in marketing people in
engineering
you want to focus on the people who are
right there within your space
so instead of going with the people in
tech go with the
machine learning engineers in healthcare
meetup if you can find it because those
are going to be people that are more
aligned with what you want
which makes for better networking
but yeah great great question um it's
just hard for me to provide some
recommendations based on that because
i i can't keep track of everything
globally and they're popping up
everywhere but that's a great question
so the next one i've touched on this
plenty of times
as you can imagine this is another top
priority for me especially as it relates
to job searching
is linkedin if you do not have a profile
create one before you go to bed tonight
it doesn't have to be perfect
but you have to start somewhere there's
also a webinar that i facilitated on
here so
if you find your way and if somebody
could do this in the chat that would be
really really helpful
so on udacity's youtube page there is a
playlist for career webinars
this will go on there once it's finished
and recorded but there's a webinar that
i facilitated on there
two of them actually one is about
optimizing your profile
and the second one is about engagement
and content creation
both of those will give you a very solid
head start
on how to leverage linkedin not only for
your job search but if you
want to do freelancing if you want to
start a business
but linkedin is probably by far the most
useful tool that i have ever used
related to my career
it has allowed me to fast track past
some of my peers
it's allowed me to get business without
doing any sales
drawing people passively to me it's
allowed me to get requests to interview
for companies every i probably get
two or three messages a month from
people asking me to be
a career coach for them um and that's
without ever applying that's without
being aggressive about trying to reach
out to these people
but this has also been you know a couple
of years in the making of me trying to
build a brand for myself but
i didn't have a me when i was
um going through this process um i'll
continue to go through this but if
somebody could find that link
and drop it in the chat that would be
awesome if not i'll post it in the end
um if you guys can remind me it's just
gonna
it's gonna be difficult for me to take
off this screen but yeah if you can find
that
if it even if it's just the link to the
the webinars playlist that would be
really helpful
this is a big one as all of them are
these are the top tips
so my next tip is oh yes
awesome thank you jonathan um stop
waiting for people to give you a chance
this is one of my biggest pet peeves as
a career coach is
hearing people say nobody's giving me a
chance nobody's willing to hire me
i you know that is not the mentality
that is helpful
and sometimes it's real and i've been
there i've been in that position even as
a career coach
knowing everything that i needed to do
and still feeling like nobody's giving
me a chance
you have to push through that you have
to go around that you have to stop
waiting for other people if you want to
work in the healthcare space
don't wait to get a healthcare job to
start working on healthcare projects
find open source projects create your
own projects
write articles build a name for yourself
as an expert in that
area do what you can do control what you
can because this mentality
waiting for somebody to give you a
chance is going to keep you
exactly where you are so find ways to
create those opportunities for yourself
volunteer reach out to that person who's
starting their own machine learning
consulting agency or you know they're
they're doing freelance data analytics
work
ask them if you can volunteer to help
them for a couple of hours a week
do what you can it is hard out here it
is
very tough to break into an industry is
very tough to change careers
and if you sit there and say poor me i
wish somebody would give me a chance i
have all the skills but don't have the
experience
you're not going to make it very far you
need to be aggressive about creating
those opportunities for yourself
because that's what you can control you
can control what you do
and that will it will create such a
freedom
that you will start to learn how to do
that even better and even better and
even better so even if you're in a job
that you love
but you know what your next step is
start looking at those job descriptions
now
use those job descriptions as your road
map find the gaps
and where you are now to where you want
to be and start looking for ways to
create those experiences proactively
so that you're not just sitting in your
comfort zone for three years and then
saying okay i want to be here
work your way up to that be intentional
about where you want to go
and find ways you can sometimes do that
within your current role
sometimes you have to go outside of that
sometimes you might have to freelance
sometimes that you might have to
do volunteer work sometimes you might
have to take an internship with a small
business owner
do what you can and do what you need to
do
because this mentality here of waiting
for people to give you a chance is only
going to hold you back
and the more comfortable you get with
creating that for yourself
the better um because i've had to deal
with this so many different times and
i'll share this story with you all
because i think it's relevant
very similar to some of you all who are
taking
these nanodegree courses in 2016 i took
a resume writing course
so i didn't start off as a career coach
i didn't get to
finish a resume writing course and start
applying for career coaching jobs people
wouldn't hire me because i didn't have
enough skills and i didn't have enough
experience so i worked with family and
friends and helped them with their
resumes i
spoke at churches for free to get new
clients i
did webinars i was doing free things all
the time
until i was able to charge and then i
charged
way less than i should have been
charging because i wanted more clients
and i just worked my way up and to the
point now
that's four years four years is a long
time
but it's also a very small amount of
time in the grand scheme of your career
so if you can do this over time and stay
consistent
it will work out extremely well in your
favor
and even more probably for you all
because you have a technical skill set
that's in demand
everybody on linkedin thinks they're a
career coach but you all have
an extremely in demand skill set that
you can leverage
throughout the rest of your career so
don't pity yourself that impostor
syndrome
get rid of it as much as as much as i i
have to deal with it myself
i have to continue to deal with that i
have to continue to fight that
it's not something that you ever get
over it's something that is a daily
reminder to say
i am qualified i am good enough and if
i'm not
let me get there and let me take it into
my own hands to
facilitate that i'm not going to wait
for somebody else to give me that
opportunity
take agency of what you can because
that's going to get you closer to your
goal than waiting for it
uh and that touches on this point
volunteer work is still experienced
if you have to do work for free join the
club
we know that you have a very high
in-demand skill set we know that your
skill set demands a pretty
hefty sum of money related to it
but if people aren't begging knocking
down your door
to hire you you're not too good to work
for free
i'm not an advocate for free work let me
make that clear i do not want people out
here taking unpaid internships and
working for free
unless you feel like it's going to get
you closer to your goal
um i think that it's extremely valuable
i've done
a total of four internships in my career
one of them was paid
the other three were all unpaid but all
three of those have
really contributed to me getting to
where i am and so
do not think you're too good especially
if people aren't begging
begging you to come work for them um do
not
go above and think that you're beyond
working for free
because it can be the only way sometimes
for you to gain experience
where employers are not willing to hire
you it can be a little bit difficult in
certain industries
but that's still no excuse to not try to
not reach
out to people find the people who are
doing it find the small startups
um and reach out and say hey i just
really need to find some some experience
i need to get some
i need to apply what i know in my head
and get something to put on my resume
i'm willing to work a couple hours for
free
even if it's entry-level data scraping
do what you have to do
that is i can't stress it enough do what
you have to do
um kevin says right now i'm thinking i'm
good enough smart enough and
gosh darn it people like me yes um
sometimes it helps to just write that
down i i think i posted on linkedin
the other day that you know don't
internalize rejection because
that is going to just is really going to
eat at you it's going to just suck
and drain your motivation so if you
apply for a job and don't get it
or if you apply for a job and get an
interview and don't get it do not
internalize that what i mean by that is
do not say i didn't get it that means i
must not be good enough
i didn't get it that means i'm not
qualified enough
sometimes they hired their friend
sometimes
you were overqualified sometimes you
were qualified
but you just didn't fit that culture
which is saving them and you time in the
long run
sometimes things just happen and so when
you're going through this process it is
important for you to reflect
it is important to you for you to be
somewhat critical to say how could i
have done better
not why what did i do wrong those are
two different questions what did i
do wrong and how can i do better are two
different questions i don't want you to
ask what did i do wrong i want you to
ask
how can i do better does that mean
continuing to build your portfolio
adding more relevant projects doing more
prep work in advance of your interviews
applying for a more specified target of
companies
those are things that i want you to do
those are things that you can control
you can't control whether or not someone
likes you you can't control whether or
not someone else had a referral
what you can control is how to make
yourself better moving forward
so i have a question yeah go ahead
okay so um human should like you know
have a reflection if you got rejected
and to know
what happened exactly and so on so the
main
issue is that that's why what i think
perhaps i might be wrong but
that's what i think that companies don't
give you feedback
why you have been rejected so how can i
figure out
that rejection so in order to do the
reflection you know it's like a loop
you know what i mean it's like a loop
but like i can't get out so okay i want
to do the reflection
but how can i do reflection without
feedback yeah you know what i mean
oh yeah and another question but after
you answered me this
sure yeah hold on to that one so i say
always ask for feedback even though most
of the times you won't get it
sometimes you will um always ask just in
case
but one of the things that people don't
oftentimes know is that a lot of
companies have actual policies in place
where they tell their recruiters do not
provide feedback
their hr managers who are telling their
people do not provide feedback if they
ask
and part of that is just kind of risk
management
and them trying to avoid potential
discrimination
lawsuits because people can take that
feedback and they can misconstrue it and
hire a lawyer and say you didn't hire me
because you're
discriminated discriminating against me
and so a lot of companies have those
policies in place
just to protect themselves from those
potential discrimination suits
the other thing to think about is that
if you're a recruiter
you're not just hiring for one job a
year you have
a list of jobs that you're hiring for so
if you have 200 candidates
if you're interviewing 10 people for
each job i don't have time to sit here
and say
hey you know what would have been great
on your resume or hey you know what have
been really awesome if you mentioned
during your interview
they don't have the time they don't have
the capacity to do that at all times and
so
you can't expect them to give you
feedback what i say to do
is go back through that job description
ask yourself do i have every single one
of these things 100
if not can i take an online course
can i volunteer can i
work on a project that's related to that
so that i can be better moving forward
you don't always have the feedback to
know that but then if you lose out on
that opportunity with that company
that's a completely different experience
of you applying for a different
opportunity
so you can't always use that feedback
either because sometimes it's just not a
good fit
sometimes there was someone better than
you and you can't control that
so think about like what are some areas
that you might be able to improve on
and then just try to go about it that
way that would be my best recommendation
but yeah a lot of companies they avoid
that feedback just
out of fear of getting sued um yeah and
kevin says they aren't always honest yes
one go-to
is you we decided to move forward with
somebody who better fit what we were
looking for
very generic very bland whatever answer
to get you to
move on and leave them alone probably
because they don't have a whole lot of
time to help you
like the global response yes it is the
global response
and trust me when i tell you i've
probably received it as many times as
you have so i
know what it feels like um and kevin
dropped in the chat networking can be
good for feedback
absolutely um gotten good feedback from
recruiters
but then again you're you're probably
going to get feedback from those people
who you've taken
time to build a relationship with not
that random person who you reached out
to on linkedin and sent the resume and
asked for a referral
probably going to be those people that
you met through other channels or
showcase you know i'm a genuine person
i'm likable
help me um those tend to work out a
little bit better yeah
um what was your other question okay so
the other question regarding the
volunteering one
so uh i'm currently working like as a
volunteer and one of the main issues
is like how to translate the
volunteering work
into the reality in order to make the
external which is
in this case the recruiter understand
what i was doing
and how connected to the job description
that i am applying for
you know what i'm saying yeah great
question so i think
one be be somewhat critical about what
you're volunteering for
if you're just volunteering and it's not
related to what you want to do
find something that is more closely
related that's not to say that
work experience in general isn't
valuable but if someone if you're
working for someone
and they're not paying you you can be a
little bit more critical in saying hey
this is what i'm trying to do i want to
work on tasks that are a little bit more
related to that
obviously you're not going to approach
it with that same tone but
you know find a way to have that
conversation to say hey
i've been doing a lot of this work um
i'm really trying to get here
is there a way that i can be involved in
something that's a little bit more
closely related to that
i think that that's a conversation that
you want to have if it's not possible
find another opportunity that is more
closely related
um i'm i'm one of those people it's like
i i do not stay with something if it
doesn't if it no longer serves me
that goes for employers that goes for
clients that goes for
professional organizations you know it's
it's it's not
good to develop those one-sided
relationships in general even if it's
with an employer
another thing is to that your
application materials
your resume your cv your linkedin
profile should be more future focused
than past focus
and that's something that i forgot to
mention earlier people like
this is what i've done this is what i've
done this is what i've done but
none of it relates to what you want to
do so you should be building your resume
building your linkedin profile branding
yourself
with this in mind not with all of this
in the past in mind
because again thinking about your resume
like a tailored
proposal saying this is a document that
i'm putting together
that showcases my ability to get this
job
this is not a document where i just
regurgitated
my five past job descriptions into
bullet points
this is me taking what i've done and
saying what things about that
are most relevant to what i want to do
then i'm going to build my bullet points
around that
if it's unrelated leave it off or find
something better to replace it with
that's how you want to approach it and
thinking about how can i transition
my my strategy to be more focused here
than more focused on everything that
i've done in the past
does that make sense yeah absolutely
makes sense
yeah and then just lastly i would say
this is probably one of the biggest
mistakes i see people make all the time
not just job search related
always document your experience
especially if you're volunteering
if you are not keeping track of the
impact that you're making
you're making a big mistake if you're
not keeping track of the projects that
you're working on
if you're not finding ways to you know
quantitatively and qualitatively gather
feedback and data from your work
to be able to showcase that to future
employers you're missing a huge
opportunity this isn't to pick on
anybody
but i say this to people who are in
their dream jobs now
like what are you what impact are you
having because when you go to apply for
a job
every single job opening ever
is a problem that needs to be solved so
if you just say this is what i do this
is what i do that's what i do that's
what i do
you're missing a huge opportunity to say
this is how i've improved the company
that i'm with
this is how i improved that business
that i worked with two years ago
this is how i solve that problem that
was really really major
that's going to be appealing to the
employers because they're going to say
hmm
if you did that there you can probably
do that here
that makes me excited to want to talk to
you that sets you apart from the
competition
because if i have a machine learning
engineer role that i'm interviewing for
and i have
eight data analysts who are applying for
that i'm going to want to hire
and speak to the data analyst who said
that i've increased efficiency of the
team
i've reduced costs i've
done whatever focus on that impact and
document that experience is hugely
valuable um that's what
everybody should be doing i agree with
you 100 about like the impact
like it's it's absolutely valuable
more than anything um just one more
question if you don't mind
uh so you have mentioned about like you
know connecting and link it in and
network
and you should like instead of like
connecting with
hr people or the recruiters you should
connect with the people who are in the
same room as you right yeah so
right now what you are saying is kind of
the opposite
of what i am hearing over i'm of what
i'm hearing from
people who kind of have some experience
in linking in or even on youtube
uh that like they always like
encouraging like go and try and find the
recruiter and
send them a message or send her a
message and tell them hey i applied i'm
interested in this position and blah
blah blah
all these things so it's kind of
confusing here right now because
they are the majority of them they are
saying what i just said and what you
what you're saying is
kind of the opposite so like can you
give me your perspective about this part
yeah that's a good question
and i think it's important to recognize
that you don't have to agree with
everything i say
um you're there's not going to be any
any career coach in the world who's
going to say something that everybody
agrees with universally
i think there's two different mindsets
and two different philosophies from the
people that you're hearing from
so what they're saying to me is here's
how to get a job most quickly
i'm not i'm not trying to teach that i'm
trying to teach people to how
how to build the most successful career
i'm not in the space of like how to land
a job as fast as possible
i don't coach like that i don't want
people to do that because what happens
is those people end up getting a job
very quickly
and they end up hating it or they end up
getting it and they're like this isn't
what i expected this isn't what i was
hoping to do
or they end up like most of my students
who do those things
and they fall into the ocean of
everybody else who's doing what's easy
they're focusing on the recruiters hey
quick message they're trying to get it
and they get it there's nothing
beneficial about that moving forward
what i teach is long-term career success
i'm trying to help people
design their lifestyle i'm trying to
help people get here i don't
really care about you know getting
a job i want people to get the right job
to get a good job to get a job that is
in alignment with where they want to be
in life
so that may be where the differences are
but also just keep in mind like these
are just things to add to your tool belt
if you're doing that
that's fine i'm not saying don't do that
stuff at all
what i'm saying from my experience what
i've seen work well for me my students
and my clients
is going this other route that other
people aren't going
um and that that that's not to say that
you can't do a little bit of both
um but you have to figure out what works
for you applying online for some people
has worked really well i've seen it but
they tend to fall in the smaller
minority of people the people who i see
have success are the people who are
networking first
the people who are leveraging linkedin
actively the people who are
building those mutually beneficial
relationships and getting those
referrals those are the people that i
see
land jobs at the top companies um and
build that long-term career
success that i'm talking about so yeah
um
and then another another tip to keep in
mind open
um keep an open mind to lower level
roles again
we're living in the midst of a global
pandemic
unlike anything we've really seen before
and that has had devastating impacts on
the job market
it is okay for you to take a role that
is not
where you ideally want to be but is
something that could get you closer to
that point
so you know if you let's say for example
you are trying to get a machine learning
engineer role and you don't have a ton
of experience maybe you
just graduated with your master's degree
a year ago and you don't have any work
experience
there's nothing wrong with taking an
entry level data analyst role
it may be above you in terms of your
your skill set
however that allows you to go in and
crush it
that allows you to go in and absolutely
do so well in that role
that you can either be considered for a
higher level role
or you have more relevant experience
than nothing
and so humble yourselves a little bit
if you're in that position not
everybody's there but if you are in a
position where you're saying
i could take a lower level role it might
not be the most engaging thing in the
world
but if you're not competitive for these
roles
then you need to take a step back and
that's okay
because even if you're in an entry-level
data analyst role even if you're an
entry-level cloud role entry-level
software developer role
those are still amazing jobs to have
right now let me tell you
a lot of these jobs are starting off
making well
more than what you need to to cover your
means
and so keep an open mind to those lower
level roles even if you know that you're
a little bit more qualified
it's okay it is okay for you to take a
step back in order to help you take a
step forward
i see kevin asked the question do you
think it's a good idea to get involved
with a startup just to build a minimum
viable product to get portfolio
experience
absolutely i think startups have so much
potential that people oftentimes
throw them out because they have an idea
in their head about what a startup is
they see they hear the word startup and
they think one thing
there are startups with 200 employees
there are startups with three employees
there are startups that will allow you
flexibility there that that a full-time
job won't have
so let me give you kind of this example
if you're working for
a startup that has no data team
maybe they're hiring you to be a data
analyst they're not going to be
you know oftentimes not going to be
against you
exploring your machine learning
algorithms that you're learning in your
nanodegree project
they're oftentimes not going to say hey
we don't want you to try that new data
science technique that you learned on
linkedin today
they're going to be more flexible
because you are the expert you're the
technical expert
as long as you're getting the work done
and you can continue to explore and try
different things
if you work for amazon or google or
netflix
you're probably going to be like this at
your job you're going to be working on
one product
you're going to be doing one thing
probably very frequently until you have
absolutely mastered that
and kind of are in that specialized
space obviously you know that's not
everybody's experience
but those startups can be extremely
valuable in offering you the flexibility
to try
things to use new things that you're
learning
um and and that can be an extremely
valuable experience
plus they're oftentimes not as
competitive as those major companies
so you know they they oftentimes don't
have talent acquisition teams so they
don't have recruiters
on staff it's you know two developers
and a sales person right they don't have
a recruiter
so it helps if you reach out and say hey
um are you guys doing anything on the
data side of things or are you doing
anything on um with cloud
i'd love to jump in and see how i can be
helpful or how i can be useful
um you know have a conversation with
them see if they're willing to hire you
part-time
see if they'll pay you 20 bucks an hour
or you know whatever is fair as you're
kind of entering there
that could potentially lead to a
full-time role if the business continues
to grow
but in that meantime build your
portfolio
get real world experience apply the
things that you're learning
because experience at a startup
experience volunteering
experience working with a small business
owner is
ten times better than zero experience so
again it's okay to humble yourself it's
okay to take a step back
especially these days when we're dealing
with a pandemic that has devastated the
job market
you all are you all know why you chose
these programs you all are developing
skill sets that are so
there are going to be so normal in five
to ten years
and if you start this process now even
if it's hard
i promise you it's not going to be you
know harder than when
every company has a data analyst on
their team which means that they've
invested in data
which means that they're considering
algorithms for machine learning they may
be
thinking about how they can implement
computer vision into their new
startup idea and so you know it's okay
to grind
now to really really receive those
benefits down the line you guys are in a
good place
i don't want you to feel like you're
you're failing because
people aren't knocking down your door to
hire you i know that's what it
they make it seem like in the tech
industry but that's not always the case
and it's okay
to start a little bit lower than you may
have initially hoped this
my advice would be completely different
if we were talking last year
very similar but you know there's a lot
things that are very different now than
have ever been so lastly
keep your head up as i mentioned before
you all know what you're doing you're
here
which says a ton um that that you are
here as a udacity student but also
here attending this webinar if you keep
this up if you stay consistent
it's very difficult to fail i don't know
if i know any hard-working people who
aren't successful like at least
eventually
um the people who focus on in demand
which all of you are doing
everything that you are learning is in
demand now and will only continue to
grow
udacity doesn't build content that isn't
in alignment with that
ideology so keep grinding now it may you
may not see the benefits right away
but you will start to see it as
time goes on sometimes it just is just
helpful to
kind of keep your head down keep
grinding and and really
be great be grateful practice gratitude
i know
one of the things that i've had to
really practice is thinking about
i i'm where i i dreamed of being four
years ago
i still feel like oh i want to be there
i want to be in this place
i should be there but i'm not and it
makes you kind of doubt yourself but
then think about like
five years ago i never would have
imagined i would be this smart
i never would have imagined i would be
able to do the things that i'm able to
do
with what i'm learning with the
experience that i'm gaining with the
things that i'm doing so sometimes it
helps to just kind of
take time and be grateful for yourself
be grateful for the work that you've put
in thus far
um you know focus on the things that you
can control
a lot of the things i've talked about
are outside of job search strategies a
lot of this is emotional
and a lot of times especially us as men
i don't know if they're
they're probably only a couple of women
in here which is great
um but you know even even just in
general especially people in tech we
oftentimes
throw away the emotions the emotions are
not important but it's extremely
important when you go through this
process
when you go through a job search you're
taking blows to your ego
every single day that you don't get
hired and that takes a toll on you
in your overall life it's not just your
career
it it depends on how you're able to
provide for your family
it values your self-worth sometimes and
so
it's important that you recognize the
emotional aspect of this
if this is stressful if you're having a
tough time
you know reach out for mental mental
health counseling
i've done it plenty of times it's one of
the biggest things that i can recommend
for people who are going through a job
search
talk to somebody who is a professional
in that
the way you're a professional and what
you do and i'm a professional in what i
do
i talk to someone who's a professional
in helping me to recognize that i'm
doing the best that i can
and that i need to do things like
practice gratitude and focus on
controlling what i can
because those things are only going to
help and those other things
are going to make this process so much
more difficult
so um i know we went over time by quite
a bit
but i really appreciate you all joining
um i
i love the small group interaction um
this was a great
great session i hope and i hope you all
are a little bit more prepared
kind of moving forward for 2021 and i
would just say lastly um
check out some of those previous
webinars that i mentioned there's a
playlist of i think it's over 70 now
maybe 60 60 to 70
different webinars like this from all of
the different career coaches that that
work here at udacity
so find the ones that are related to the
topics that you want to explore
and and just kind of take take take a
look at those
um how can we get in touch if we have
questions so one of the things that i
would say
is that we don't have a lot of capacity
to do one-on-one very similar to like
the recruiters
um so it's very difficult for us to kind
of respond to emails and things like
that especially with more in-depth
questions
so what i would highly recommend for all
of you if this was helpful if you want
to learn more
if you have the ability please schedule
those one-on-one coaching sessions if
you
paid for the nanodegree program some
scholarships do some don't
but each nanodegree program that you pay
for sign up for you get four career
coaching sessions so
in your career portal where you have
like the access to submit your resume
and your linkedin profile there should
be a link there for you to schedule a
one-on-one call
you're more than welcome to schedule
with me or any of the other coaches
on staff this is probably one of the
most talented teams i've ever worked on
so you're in good hands with whoever you
move forward with
but those one-on-one um calls are really
good for you to say
i attended this webinar with brett one
of the things that he really talked
about was virtual networking and i think
that that's something i'd like to spend
this 30 minutes
focusing on um or if you say you know
one of the things that brett talked
about was really narrowing your focus
can we have a conversation about
figuring out what it is that i really
want to do and then creating a plan to
move forward from that
i don't want anybody to go through this
process just
wondering aimlessly you need a plan you
need to focus
and then from there it helps you to be
more strategic about how you can move
forward but yeah
um lily if you want to feel free to
connect with me on linkedin i also have
a ton of different resources there
um articles how-to guides i post content
here and there not so much lately
because i've been really busy
but you can stay in touch there if you
do have quick questions i'm always
available for those on linkedin but
don't reach out and say hey i need you
to look at my resume
those are much more in-depth things but
if you have like a quick
question i'm more than happy to help or
redirect you to scheduling a one-on-one
call
um but yes thank you all again so much
especially those of you who might be in
um
less ideal time zones but thank you all
for attending
and yeah we will wrap up
thank you um also there there's the
student hub that you can
check out um for those channels we do um
career
office hours there as well mines mine
are usually on wednesdays
from six to seven um and then all the
other coaches have hours as well so
stay tuned within those and also um
keep an eye out on the udacity events
channel i always recommend that people
bookmark that and just check that here
and there you can always rsvp in advance
and get those reminders but yeah thanks
again for attending i hope you all
learned a lot or at least learned
something and i appreciate you
you joining in today i hope you all have
a great rest of your night
thank you
you